please come factory this year yes your
air fresheners you know I use these when
I don't have any Cologne
I'll just wrap this in my around my
throat put it up girls be like you smell
like a cop I'm not the Andrea and this
is car collector what's up
she made my Kipps and I met my crib and
I want to show you a collection of my
car oh my god mmm they survived me over
here let's start right here big Matt
right now we standing next to the 1964
Buick Riviera as you can see you know we
went on and put the sway we got the
suede in here I got the googoo Chi
headliner who'd you hear you gotta go
all the way around you can't just go
yeah you gotta touch it you gotta rub it
all the way around I got about seven
coats are clear on here so at night is
so wet it look like a glass riding down
the street big man like it this is a new
2013 Range Rover big truck but it's fast
you know this thing has 510 horsepower I
mean you can dress up and go to meetings
in it or you just like I say it take the
family out on the excursion
yeah you know because this is in LA they
only come in black this is 2013 2013
rolls-royce ghost 8-speed woodgrain you
know I bought this car because it was
everyday cars like whoo but I can still
get a driver to take me and my wife out
to dinner this is beautiful but it is a
rolls-royce isn't a rolls-royce is all
about the interior let's take a look at
a beautiful white interior yes it's so
classy it's the most sort of rolls-royce
combination this is an English car these
rains they're all the time oh here's a
little something you just got this car
so here's something you might not know
what comes with you bro ah God I didn't
know that what there
Wow so tell me about this car this car
is all flash it's the only t bucket I've
ever seen that has wire wheels on it
this is a 1932 Ford Roadster we got
these wire rims on it
I got 26 inches in the back with a three
stroke engine with the straight street
drag pipes it's gotta be amazing to hear
as well
it is you want to hear let's fire it up
let's fire it up you got to climb in it
like on the old Beverly Hillbillies
we got a kill switch on
Mike I'm a hotrod guy I love this car
but this is not your only hot rod is it
no it's not man I have a 1957 Chevy
Belair that I've been working on now for
about six months new Camaro engine I
took the old original 57 Chevy engine
out of it and put a new custom chrome
engine in it it's going to be basically
everything new underneath deal with that
classic style on top so you'll be
getting a 1957 Chevy in 2013 man my girl
gonna be mad when I get that guy Mike
this has been great you have a great
collection of cars nice you have these
are the old-school 60s which I love you
have the best of the modern cars yeah
and your hot rods this is great
much-loved GQ you're definitely in our
car club all right
to see more of Mike and his cars don't
forget to subscribe to GQ calm